when it comes to testing both race cars
and street-legal cars there's a
benchmark that all car makers base
things on the North Loop of the
Nurburgring racetrack
it's nearly 21 kilometers long was 73
curves and more than 300 meters of
elevation change car makers run tests
here and try to break records it's just
the right track for Porsches newest Road
vehicle the 911 gt3 with 368 kilowatts
of power Lisa from Porsche says the best
car is the one that covers the distance
in the shortest time he says that if
you're fast enough on the Nurburgring
you'll be fast enough anywhere in the
world a new vocational assistive all of
the village men but the North Loop is
different from most race courses since
it features a challenging variable
driving surface posting a good time on
this track means a huge boost to your
image the North Loop puts a considerable
strain on tires so to get the best time
Porsche changes the tires after each lap
[Music]
Raymond Franklin Issa explains that to
set records preparation has to be
perfect the tires have to be there
everything has to have been carefully
planned and the drivers have to have
practiced the weather has to cooperate
and the team has to be highly motivated
after months of meticulous preparation
everything is focused on just a few
minutes when everything has to work
perfectly
Porsche is using tires their customers
will also get on their gt3 their sporty
semi slicks made specifically for the
gt3
that would hang in the NSA is pointing
up from Porsche says the main thing is
drivability on the North Loop in
particular the driver has to trust the
vehicle getting feedback from the car
and be able to anticipate its reactions
that's the only way to get the car to
the limit and reach top speeds a lot of
power or great tires aren't enough
everything has to be well matched to
achieve the absolute optimal result
muscle is often under up custom signed
us is perfect to optimal scope the clock
is ticking now everything has to be just
right only the best of the best managed
to stay below 7 minutes and 20 seconds
on a lap of the North Loop and among
those is the new gt3
[Music]
it manages a lap time of seven minutes
12 seconds and 7/10 the engineers are
thrilled with the results of their hard
work race car driver large cannon says
he felt relaxed driving the car it
responded well and he didn't have any
critical moments during the two laps he
says they knew the car had the potential
to make that time and he says it's
important for it to be easy for the
customer to experience he thinks that
won't be a problem if I'm fire faba is
offered in court for diocese relative to
this fact Porsche proved its mettle on
the North Loop back in 2013 with a super
sports car the 918 Spyder the company
was the first to post a North Loop lap
time of under seven minutes with a
series production street-legal vehicle
this time another 918 is being put to
the test
[Music]
and Porsche easily confirms the
potential of its radical hybrid with a
lap time of 6 minutes and 58 seconds
of course not every Porsche customer
will be in a position to achieve times
like that still every driver profits
from a car that handles smoothly even at
top speeds
[Music]
[Applause]